hey what's up guys my name is Ryan
welcome back to my game engine series so
today below something a little bit
different first of all I will you guys
to watch the previous episode if you
haven't already
that's us finishing up all of the iron
gooey stuff that I wanted to actually do
now that we've done that we're going to
move on to a very big new topic called
rendering now for first of all let's
talk about what's different in this
episode my computer has just completely
broken himself like just will not work
at all which is all great and I could
probably fix it if I had enough time but
unfortunately I don't have time because
at the moment I'm working full-time of
course a TA on frostbite
I'm also renovating my apartment I'm
also getting married in about a month so
I have to do a lot of wedding
preparation in my life is just
completely hectic but I still really
wanted to make a video for you guys
today so I thought you know what let's
just talk about stuff today because this
whole rendering topic that we're about
to dive into is so incredibly
complicated and just just enormous that
you just really cannot plan enough and
if I think about how many times I've
written a renderer before and how many
times I've written rendering API
abstractions before it doesn't matter
how many times I do this I'm gonna be 50
years old and I'm still gonna be writing
them a different way because it just you
just it's just incredible like it's just
crazy how just complicated and how much
stuff there is to actually know and I
still don't really know what I'm doing
so because my computer's broken I can't
really do anything on it I've gone onto
paper and we're actually gonna talk
about a lot of what we're gonna do in
the coming weeks because what we're
going to do now in hazel is write a
renderer basically okay so what does
that mean
we're gonna talk today we're gonna talk
about what that means exactly and next
week what I want to do is actually put
together probably like a PowerPoint
presentation with like diagrams and like
the structure of the API and everything
we're doing in more of a formal kind of
format this video right now is actually
going live for everyone at the same time
so patrons aren't getting this video
early just because of the fact that I've
had no computer and I'm probably
to edit this on my laptop which is gonna
be terrible anyway that aside everyone's
getting this at the same time which is
cool because I can get your feedback
immediately and that's gonna be quite
good because next week what I want to
actually do is record a video where I
actually talk about the design of this
whole thing right and that's gonna be
like with a PowerPoint presentation
because there's no way I can just talk
myself into this it's just going to be
too much information and it's gonna be
very hard to kind of visualize if it's
not drawn like like as an actual diagram
for you guys so that's what's gonna
happen next week but today I'm just
gonna talk about this I'm just gonna
give you my experience which is
rendering in general and talk about what
this means for hazel and like it just
we're gonna talk okay so step one and
the first thing that I have my list here
is just that it's a really hard and
complex topic which for we define what
the topic actually is so rendering what
is rendering involved why do we need it
in the game engine you know what what is
its purpose why is it in hazel what does
it do okay so rendering refers to
basically our ability to draw graphics
on the screen now what that means
usually is well hey I have like this 3d
model I want to draw I have this world I
want to draw I have this whole scene
that I've built up I want to render this
in a in a real-time fashion that is you
know fast enough to actually be
real-time so probably 60 frames per
second which is 16.7 milliseconds per
frame and I want it to be interactive
which means that there has to be fairly
low latency between input and actual you
know doing something and affecting the
rendering in some way that is
essentially one rendering is now why is
it so complicated well the way that we
achieve rendering that is fast and that
is capable of producing high fidelity
graphics which again is some say I'm not
professional at all though I haven't
produced something that there is high
fidelity right which is again a term
that like it to each their own right
look what does high resolution was
what's high-fidelity graphics to you
right a lot of what you see today is
maybe some of the some of the like new
games that are being released by huge
company
you know you see like I might even play
some of them he don't know if I can
copyright wise but you know stuff like
the new ray-tracing stuff in battlefield
5 you know you've got all of these kind
of high fidelity graphics that are
coming out and we perceive them as high
fidelity usually because they're close
to being photorealistic which means that
that rendering technology is actually
capable of someone producing something
that is looks like a movie or a
photograph in real time right can people
compare it to how the real world works a
lot and you have these things like
physically based rendering which is
actually rendering based on physical
properties of surfaces and like how
light works and photons and all that
kind of stuff and that's kind of our
pursuit our like us actually pursuing a
way to render photorealistic graphics in
real time because we can we can more or
less render photorealistic graphics
right but doing it in real time is
really really challenging and there's
like a huge like huge huge like thing
going on with with people obviously
trying to achieve that in real time but
that's still kind of not really quite
there yet and certainly this kind of ray
tracing hardware is coming out in the
form of like r-tx for example on it on
video that stuff is definitely like
stepping into the right direction
because everyone knows that ray tracing
is how you have a lot of offline render
s and non real-time renderers so render
is the people use for like movies and
stuff like that how they're able to
achieve photo realism like quote unquote
right is by using ray tracing kind of
renderers but anyway getting ahead of
myself here it's very complicated
because apart from doing all of that the
way that we actually achieve that high
performance or performance that is at
the level where it's it's possible for
us to do this stuff in real time and
still achieve a high fidelity look we
need to use something called the GPU
which is the graphics processing unit
it's a dedicated piece of hardware that
resides in most computers right
sometimes it's integrated into our CPU
there are various architectures for how
this hardware is actually set up but
ultimately it is a dedicated chip that
is on our computer or whatever device
were using that is capable of performing
or executing
certain mathematical operations are
algorithms that are very common for
common like rendering tasks essentially
or common graphics processing tasks so a
lot of what we have to do with graphics
is display a large number of pixels on
the screen if we have a full HD display
that's about 2 million pixels we need a
way to determine the color for each
pixel usually this is independent of
every other pixel so it's possible to do
that stuff in parallel right that is
something that a GPU is usually quite
good at okay other things like you know
we deal a lot with four component
vectors we deal a lot with 4x4 matrices
we have Hardware optimizations for
operations like that on the GPU which is
why it's faster than doing these kinds
of things on the CPU so parallel
processing and then a lot of specific
math operations is the gist of it
obviously we have specific like ray
tracing processes and other kind of
architectures that may have a lot of
things but that's kind of just to dumb
it down to keep it basic it's because of
that is because the map that we kind of
want to use for rendering graphics is
faster to do on the GPU because of
dedicated hardware for that and then
also we have a large like huge
parallelization essentially the less
let's do a lot of operations in just at
the same time essentially like in
parallel okay so to interface with this
GPU we have to use something called a
rendering API now I do have an OpenGL
series which you can check out but I do
realize as time goes on OpenGL is
becoming less and less like a thing and
I mean look me personally like if you
ask me personally what is Yann Cherica
what is the churn I'm going to use and
here's high performance engine is it
gonna be OpenGL of course not OpenGL is
not something that I can recommend using
if you're going for bleeding edge
cutting like edge I don't know I want to
make the best game enter the best
graphics rendering end and in 2090 of
course not you don't want OpenGL you
probably will if you absolutely at the
top edge you want probably the Vulcan or
DirectX 12 right we are not a huge game
studio or a huge rendering powerhouse
that is capable of implementing a Vulcan
our director
while rendre immediately in a way that
can also teach it to all of you guys
because Vulcan and DirectX fall
specifically looking at Vulcan though is
extremely complicated those of you who
have not taken a good look at Vulcan I
like I am there is no one to me capable
of explaining exactly how like the
Vulcan swap chain actually works and hat
like OpenGL code right I can I can write
you probably a physically based
rendering from memory in OpenGL like all
API commands everything just correct
right I can do that because they're
simple Vulcan I probably wouldn't be
able to draw a triangle for you in
Vulcan off the top of my head no wait no
I definitely wouldn't be able to write
and I've worked with Vulcans since
before it was released actually so I do
have quite a bit of elf experience and
yet I'm not able to do that because it's
incredibly complicated you're like
fifteen hundred lines of Kurtis on me to
render a triangle so that's why I've
specifically gone with OpenGL as a
rendering API in the beginning why is it
is it because it's the best choice
obviously not but the thing is I can't
spend a hundred videos setting up a
Vulcan swap chain to show you guys this
because that's gonna lose a lot of
viewers and that's not gonna be
interesting okay and it's not something
that we need why because I'd much rather
get hazel to the point where I can
render like a PVR scene in 3d and then
be like hey you know what maybe now
we'll implement Vulcan because we're
getting to the point where it might be
necessary so you have to look at it from
this kind of point of view a lot of
people ask me if the way that I'm
building hazel is how I would build my
engine or if I'm making all the right
decisions I'm making the right decisions
considering it's a video series on
YouTube I want to make that absolutely
clear actually quite like this video I'm
just ranting along and venting I'm just
explaining everything's working which is
good cuz there's so many comments I've
read and so many things I want to say I
can't anyway Oh sir that being said
that's why we've kind of show up in jail
because it allows us to tap into our
graphics code and actually use it but
it's the most simple API for doing that
our OpenGL is extremely simple it's like
a ten out of ten in terms of how high
level of an abstraction it is right
we're Vulcan might be like
one directx12 might be like a three
directx 11 and like metal might be
around a 5 or 6 whereas Vulcan is like
you know on one extreme and OpenGL is on
the other extreme which is quite
interesting as well to just look at okay
so here's where it gets even more
complicated though so okay you pick a
rendering API which lets you use the
graphics card which is what you want to
do to perform rendering right that's our
task in a way but we the problem is what
the one graphics API is not enough now
OpenGL is something that happens to at
least in the past now snow more so it's
getting more deprecated and it's getting
more or less kind of removed like
channeled out whatever you want to call
it so it's a little bit different now
but in the past OpenGL was extremely
good in the sense that it just worked on
everything was almost like Java actually
I might compare it to Java because Java
worked asterisk everywhere but it was
mostly garbage right I wouldn't say
OpenGL is like just absolute garbage or
anything like that I actually quite like
OpenGL in the sense that it's just so
simple it's so nice and warm and
inviting to come back to OpenGL after
spending some time in other entering API
ascending lines is insane it's nice to
come back to OpenGL in a way even though
I still think the API is not amazing
it's still nice to come back to OpenGL
and not amazing I'm putting it lightly
by the way but anyway coming back up
gels always nice because it's so simple
right it's incredibly simple now the
thing is though and I don't even
remember where I was going with this but
the thing is when you have something
really when you go back to designing all
these rendering api's and you think
about what you actually need it becomes
a problem of what platforms essentially
am I kind of shipping on right so to
drag this back a little bit as I was
just talking earlier before I completely
forgot where I was going I was saying
that OpenGL back in the day was kind of
just
like Java in the sense that it just
worked everywhere right
I mean Windows Mac Linux Android iOS
they all ran they were all capable of
running OpenGL whereas now if you take a
look at what's happening well like you
know not saying Windows wasn't
absolutely great with it but like
Android iOS you know Mac Linux they all
kind of ran on it right but now if you
look at the state of api's what is the
best API to render on a given platform
for Windows it's DirectX 11 or DirectX
12 for Mac it's metal and Phi OS it's
metal for Linux it's Vulcan for Android
it's Vulcan
maybe GL GL es right glares but that's
for probably all the devices mostly
Vulcan right did I miss anything
for Xbox it's DirectX 12 usually and for
ps4 which I'm missing out on is certain
his own proprietary API
which I always forget the name of
because I didn't deal with it too often
and then for like the Nintendo switch I
think it might be Falcon as well to be
honest but I'm not 100 central anyway so
those kind of platforms you can see that
OpenGL is non-existent right do I pick
up in jail well nor maybe on older
Android devices is pretty much maybe the
only reason you pick up in jail right
you can still render OpenGL on Windows
but is it preferred no you should be
using DirectX if you're serious about
rendering on Windows it's as simple as
that where I'm going with this is that
you need to is set you can't get away
with using with using one rendering API
and that's why rendering becomes really
complicated well one of the reasons it
becomes complicated because you need to
do something in design an API
abstraction which hides away all of the
actual render API like calls behind your
own abstraction so that ideally you
basically or in this case hazel has its
own API it has its own rendering API and
then that rendering API could be using
either DirectX 12 could be using DirectX
11 could be using Vulcan could be using
gel could be using metal whatever right
it could be using any
during API it wants but you tell hazel I
want to upload a vertex buffer full of
data it does that how it does that using
which API that's deep that's
implementation details that we don't
want to worry about we have this
abstraction layer an API where we can
generically tell hazel upload this
vertex buffer upload this texture data
you know I want to render you know from
this index buffer three indices and with
this vertex buffer with this material
with this shader with this you know
topology I don't know just million
different details right but the point is
we tell hazel we want that hazel figures
out okay well we're running on Windows
and we're currently using DirectX 11
because that's always selected therefore
I'm gonna use that or what kind of we're
currently running on a Mac so I'm gonna
use metal I wanted you can't get the
point all right we have this abstraction
layer so that our application code
doesn't change based on what it's
running on and it will be using the
optimal rendering API on the platform
and configuration that we've actually
set up that's extremely difficult to do
okay that's extremely difficult to do
because what you need to do is draw a
line somewhere and say this is what my
API looks like that's really difficult
because the more you go on with graphics
and the further you get and the more
advanced techniques you start
implementing you may need more control
dragging the whole API line is a huge
and expensive task to do case you guys
aren't clear about what I mean by API
line is it's where you draw the
abstraction so in otherwise we're really
high level might be draw a triangle at
this location and really low level might
be like unlock my Vulcan semaphore right
that's kind of maybe the two extremes or
like you know a crewman like on releases
memory fence or whatever like it it
where you drop lines really important
right now usually what I tend to do is I
like to think of it conceptually so
things like so I just
again twice in one video man anyway so
we do it we kind of draw the line at a
point where like I might want to say I
want a vertex buffer I want an index
buffer I want a texture I want a shader
I want to you know what what API exists
on the shader well I want to find out
information about my uniform is my
attributes I want to be able to set up
uniform buffers I want to be able to
kind of upload sections of uniform
buffers I might want to retrieve
information about attributes I might
want to retrieve certain other
information right there's a lot of
things that you might want to do I might
want to get all the resources attached
to that shader such as different
textures and like samplers might be it
like how many textures how many appleís
is is share to have do I have to hook
them up to frame buffers you you have to
you have to kind of have an API that is
flexible enough that allows you to
implement all these rendering techniques
but also tracks away all of these api's
but here's the other problem
these api's do not work the same way
right these api's do not work the same
way
OpenGL is completely different to Vulcan
right I mean yes conceptually you can
abstract it out and say you know okay
how do i render a triangle conceptually
what you could say is okay well what do
I need for that I need to first of all
set up some kind of contacts all right
in Vulcan you'd have to set up like a
crazy amount of things such as like
command queues you know rendering
devices like logical devices physical
devices what what is it what else is
that queues instances I don't even
remember everything that I kind of had
all these little things you need to set
up involvement there's a lot of stuff
you need to set up whereas I'm OpenGL
MyBudget like okay fine on frame buffers
obviously in Vulcan as well like you
need to get all the scope chain you need
step you swap chaining and set up frame
busses frame buffers for each buffer in
the swap chain lots of stuff you need to
do but essentially it comes down to I
setup my context and my rendering frame
buffer right I upload a vertex buffer
with vertices I upload an index buffer
with indices I upload a shader I set my
viewport maybe and other kind of
rendering context things and then I
issue a draw call that's probably about
it right that's what I do and
obviously that process in Vulcan is
gonna require a lot more code but that
might be your kind of that might be the
steps that you need to actually render a
triangle on the screen so with that in
mind you kind of have enough to go on
where you can say I'm good I can make
this work in both Vulcan and OpenGL
because I know what I need under my
steps and they just all look different
but essentially I've drawn that line and
I have a vertex buffer class that's what
my abstraction ends right so inside that
vertex buffer class I'll have a
different different implementation of
that vertex buffer class which applies
to Vulcan in jail for example right and
then the API that will be exposed of
things like I want to create a vertex
buffer it should be this many bytes
right it should be this kind of usage
sort of like whether it's kind of
dynamic or static things like that I
want to be able to upload a section I
want to be able to maybe map the buffer
or upload a section of data to a
particular offset in the buffer so I
want that API available I want to be
able to see the size of the buffer I
want to be able to set the layout of the
buffer so that we know how to actually
render with it and what the data inside
that looks like those kinds of things
right I want to bind the buffer I want
to lots of stuff to do right but the
idea is you've created an API so that's
really the first thing that we need to
kind of do when to creator we need to
create a rendering API now there is no
way I'm going to sit down here and write
you everything every single class and
every single detail right now because
that'll be extremely lengthy and yeah
that's like designing the whole
specification we're gonna do it as we go
along but as I said next time when I
have like little PowerPoint presentation
for you guys that's where I'm gonna take
in probably some suggestions for the
comp from the comments as well from
people who are experienced in this just
because like ah look I've been doing
this for years and years and years and
years and professionally as well
obviously and I'm I'm more than open to
ideas because this kind of stuff you
know sometimes I'll learn something new
stuff and they'll be like whoa whoa I
want to revisit this whole thing and
rewrite it from scratch now that I have
this piece of information right anyway
so we designed an API we need to come up
with an API essentially where we where
we draw the line of abstraction so that
we actually
or how kind of low-level it'll be
usually what ends up happening by the
way is that you have like kind of a you
have your render API abstraction layer
and then on top of that you have a
renderer so you don't like the renderer
does not directly interface with any
rendering API but you still kind of have
that right so the render layer is where
you probably have things like your scene
graph you know any kind of batching
logic culling logic that kind of stuff
that's it like that renderer level right
um and like brenda's sorting and all of
that kind of stuff right whereas you
know the ready repair doesn't deal with
the render API is things like upload a
vertex buffer upload a texture it's like
render commands essentially but you've
extracted it out so that you can switch
out the rendering API to whatever you
want okay so that's the API that we need
to design we're going to talk about the
renderer just yet we're just going to
talk about that rendering API
abstraction that's one thing we need to
do and we'll talk about that next week
you know I've got a lot of other things
here as well you know there are things
like command cues and multi-threading
and I don't mean renderer
multi-threading I mean like Gammage and
multi-threading so it's very common for
example to actually submit commands from
your game thread or from your
application thread but all that is a
command submission so you say I want to
upload this texture or please create a
vertex buffer for me on the GPU right
what what happens with that code is it
gets queued it gets put into something
called a command queue or like a render
command Q and then what happens is the
render thread when that starts up it
goes through the list of commands and
execute them okay a load of AP I'll
actually do stuff it goes like Vulcan
and write X well for example have that
stuff in them but like GL doesn't so
usually it's common nowadays to actually
design that stuff yourself we'll have to
do that right probably and I'll show you
guys how to do that because it's quite I
don't know I it's quite cool I quite
like it even though it is sometimes
tedious but essentially you have like a
command encoder that goes through and
like it copies all the data you need for
a command plus the command itself plus
maybe like a function pointer and then
you you store all that in like a binary
buffer that's all continuous memory
that it's all kind of cash friendly and
then you kind of the render thread goes
through that and like it's almost like a
CPU reading CPU instructions where you
go through it like different op codes
and you say okay I'm doing this command
now there's a rep you know the next 12
bytes are parameters in the form of 3
floats so transmit them like that and
it's quite it's actually quite
interesting and it's very if you can
make it very efficient which is really
cool so we'll have to cover stuff like
that and we'll talk about some of the
negatives of that as well as the
positive stuff there's a lot to do with
rendering I just want you guys to
understand that I'm kind of overwhelmed
I want to design this as much as
possible I always knew this but it
happened in a way but like I just it's
almost annoying that this friend ring
that we're up to rendering now because
as I said I'm getting married next month
and I'm gonna go on a honeymoon for a
little bit of time so I'll be away and
there won't be videos here and obviously
I don't want to be worrying about
rendering architecture and hazel while
I'm supposed to be getting married so
because of that I'm just like asking you
guys to just take it easy on me for the
next month or two probably two months
like in May I should be back in action
100% but like for now I'm just gonna
still try and release a video a week but
if it's like not as saturated or not as
good as you kind of not as mind we don't
get as much done as you expect to it's
because I just kind of want to talk this
through I want to make sure we have a
solid design because this is probably
one of the most complicated parts of
hazel it's definitely the biggest system
of hazel and I definitely want to just
make sure that we get this kind of right
but also that you guys understand all
the implications of this because this is
a this is an educational series I'm not
just running hazel for myself we're
building hazel together and I want you
guys to understand how everything works
anyway I think that's about it next time
what we're actually going to do is talk
about that rendering API abstraction I'm
going to see what you guys say in the
comments but also I'm going to get that
PowerPoint presentation ready where we
actually talk about how we are going to
abstract that and
turning - and how everything's gonna
work the whole architecture of the
renderer is really what we're going to
talk about next next week and not really
the architecture of the renderer so much
as the architecture of the render API
abstraction or the rendering API
graphics API abstraction whatever you
want to call it okay so that's next week
hope you guys enjoyed this video and I
nearly fix my computer before next week
as well so this is not gonna be a fun
week anyway now we've got people from
like frostbite over in the EA studio
this week as well there's so much stuff
happening know I hope you guys enjoy
this video if you did please hit that
like button you can help support me on
patreon by gonna pet around comm for
slash the show now I need you guys
support more than ever right now because
I'm just like and just I'm thinking of
even taking like unpaid leave from work
because it's just everything just
overwhelming so I would you know I
really want to keep making these videos
for you guys because I love it right
like even though there are potentially
more important things for me to be doing
right now I really love making these
videos for you guys like you mean a lot
to me and I really do want to write this
render or for hazel it's gonna be so
cool and working with you guys as well
in that it's gonna be amazing so if you
can please support me and you'll get
access to a lot of this source code I've
already written like a render command
cute you know that runs on a different
thread I know if you run some innocent
read yet but it is a full kind of
command processor and command Q you know
that way you can submit commands I've
already written all that stuff and it
works with OpenGL and we are rendering
more than just a triangle all that stuff
is in the hazel development repository
already ready to go so if you want to
kind of jump ahead and see kind of how
this is gonna look definitely check that
out and I think that I am because that
is OpenGL I'm not sure exactly where but
I am already beginning that abstraction
so I'm playing around with things like
that
so definitely check that out and then
usually you'll get a videos a week early
I can't promise for the next like two
months basically until maybe you will
get videos early every week I'll try but
like I mean with this week I kind of
couldn't do that because my computer
maybe I'll be better
but again your spot means a lot to me
and this series just I'm telling you
like straight up would not be here
without all those wonderful supporters
so thank you so much I hope you guys
enjoy this video I will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]